It's 1984, and journalist Jack Hitt is walking up Broadway in Manhattan toward Columbia University. Jack is 27 at the time, recently out of grad school and obsessed with American history. I'm a constitution nerd, and my girlfriend and I've decided to write a book about marginalized figures in American history. Romance right there. So on this particularly romantic day, Jack was on his way to do some research. on the Revolutionary War in the stacks of Butler Library. Butler Library is one of these libraries when you walk in the front door. It looks like it has about four or five stories,
那是1984年，记者杰克·希特正沿着曼哈顿的百老汇大道走向哥伦比亚大学。当时的杰克27岁，刚读完研究生不久，对美国历史着迷。我是一个宪法迷，我和女朋友决定写一本关于美国历史中被边缘化人物的书。浪漫就在于此。所以在这样一个特别浪漫的日子里，杰克正前往巴特勒图书馆的书库，去查找关于美国独立战争的一些资料。巴特勒图书馆就是那种你一走进正门，看起来大约有四五层楼高的图书馆，
but it's actually like 12 stories underground too. Right. So I'm down like in the ninth floor and you know that setting, right? It's just books, wall-to-wall books, and there's nobody down there. It's this wonderful feeling of come off the elevator or walk down the stairs. You're in this like, just dark envelope of books.
但实际上地下也有大约12层。没错。所以我大概下到了第九层，你知道那种环境，对吧？到处都是书，四面墙都是书，而且下面一个人也没有。那种感觉非常奇妙，你刚走出电梯或者走下楼梯，就身处这样一个仿佛由书籍构成的黑暗空间里。
And each aisle is only illuminated by this little 15-minute timer that you turn when you walk down it. And so I'm heading down towards the American Revolution section. On his mind is one particular figure from the American Revolution. Someone Jack thought history had almost entirely overlooked. We'd come across this guy named James Otis, who had written this sort of inflammatory pamphlet really early on, the early 1760s, a good 10 or 15 years before the Declaration of Independence. Some people say, you know, this is the document that sort of got the ball rolling. Jack was fired up about this pamphlet. And if you're thinking this is kind of like a brochure that you get at a doctor's office, you know, with a diagram of the
而且每条走道只由一个15分钟的小定时器照明，你走进去时顺手扭动它。于是我朝着美国独立战争部门走去。他脑子里想着美国独立战争中的一个特定人物。一个杰克认为几乎被历史完全遗忘的人。我们偶然发现了这个名叫詹姆斯·奥蒂斯的人，他在很早的时候——也就是1860年代初，比《独立宣言》早了整整10到15年——写了一份颇具煽动性的小册子。有些人说，你知道的，这就是那份让事情运转起来的文件。杰克对这本小册子充满了热情。如果你认为这就像你在诊所里拿到的那种小册子，上面画着食物金字塔的图表，
food pyramid. Think again, pamphlets were how big ideas were spread at the time. They could be printed quickly and disseminated widely. And it was also the place where you might have a hot take, right? So think of the famous pamphlets that we all learn later in American history, Thomas Payne's common sense or letters from a farmer in Pennsylvania by John Dickinson. They're the ones that, you know, that lasted and were famous. And that's why my girlfriend at the time and I wanted to write this book is Otis's pamphlet deserves to be that famous. But what made the story kind of great for us is that things go sideways for Otis. Actually horribly. Tragic. That's like Shakespeare. A man, you know, soaring into greatness, crashing into unbelievable humiliation and then madness.
那就大错特错了。在那个年代，小册子是传播宏大思想的方式。它们可以被快速印刷并广泛传播。这也是你可能会发表激烈言论的地方。所以想想那些我们在后来的美国历史中都会学到的著名小册子，托马斯·潘恩的《常识》或是约翰·迪金森的《宾夕法尼亚农民来信》。它们是那些流传下来并成名的作品。这就是为什么当时的女友和我想写这本书，因为奥蒂斯的册子理应享誉同样的名声。但让这个故事对我们来说变得精彩的是，奥蒂斯的人生急转直下。实际上极其糟糕。充满悲剧色彩。就像莎士比亚戏剧一样。一个走向伟大巅峰的人，跌入难以置信的羞辱，然后走向疯狂。
And, you know, of course, I romance the idea that, you know, these dangerous ideas that he was entertaining so early on, you know, had taken him over the edge. So without the internet to rely on, Jack is looking for a book that might tell him more about this tragic proto-founding father and his inflammatory pamphlet. And I'm poking through the books looking for which ones I should check out. And I look behind one of the books and I see that there's something back there, a thin volume. hand-sewn binding. I'm like, what? Pull out some books. Pull this thing out.
而且，你知道的，我当然把这种浪漫主义色彩赋予了这些想法——他那么早就开始构思的这些危险思想，你知道的，把他逼上了绝境。因此，在没有互联网可依靠的情况下，杰克正在寻找一本能告诉他更多关于这位悲剧性的准国父及其煽动性小册子的书。我在书堆中翻找，看哪些书我该借阅。我看到一本书后面有什么东西，是一本薄薄的书，有着手工缝制的装订。我想，这是什么？抽出几本书。把这东西拉出来。
And this is the pamphlet that James Otis wrote. Wow. And this is an original copy. It's a 1764 edition of the pamphlet that made him famous. My first thought, of course, is I should steal this. And I'm thinking that in. the most virtuous way. Of course.
这就是詹姆斯·奥蒂斯写的小册子。哇。这是一份原版。是1764年让他成名的那本小册子的版本。我的第一个想法，当然是，我应该把它偷走。而且我是以最崇高的心态在这样想的。当然。
They don't know what they have. They don't appreciate it. It's rotting into dust back there behind these books. I know what it is. It's the Magna Carta of America. I know what I'm holding in my hand. Wouldn't it just sit back there and turn into dust over the next hundred years if I don't save it? It's the only moral option is to take it.
他们根本不知道自己拥有什么。他们并不珍惜它。它就烂在这些书后面的灰尘里。我知道它是什么。它是美国的《大宪章》。我知道我手里拿的是什么。如果我不拯救它，它不就会在接下来的几百年里一直坐在那里变成灰尘吗？唯一的道德选择就是把它拿走。
Right. And then the light timer cut off and I was plunged into darkness. matching the darkness of your soul. Exactly. So, of course, I crab walked out of there. Took the elevator to the ground floor and up to the sixth floor into the bright light of the rare books division and handed it to the curator. And I told her, this jewel of the American Revolution has been rotting away in the stacks.
没错。然后灯光定时器熄灭了，我陷入了黑暗之中。与你灵魂的黑暗相呼应。完全正确。所以，当然，我像螃蟹一样从那里爬了出来。乘电梯到一楼，然后上到六楼，进入珍本部的明亮灯光下，把它交给了馆员。我告诉她，这颗美国独立的明珠一直在书库里腐烂。
And I hope that they will take it and preserve it. And that's where it is today. Wow. But James Otis is still sort of, in that hidden place in American history. To tell the story of James Otis in his seminal pamphlet is to tell the story of a bolt from the blue, a spark that would electrify the American Revolution.
我希望他们能把它收下并妥善保存。这就是它今天的归宿。哇。但詹姆斯·奥蒂斯在美国历史中仍然处于某种隐秘的角落。要讲述詹姆斯·奥蒂斯和他的开创性小册子的故事，就是在讲述一道来自青天的闪电，一个将点燃美国独立战争的火花。
Before the Declaration of Independence was even a twinkle in the founding father's eyes, there was James Otis. And you could argue that the story of this pamphlet is the story of the founding document of the United States of America. from 99% Invisible in BBC studios. This is a history of the United States and 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. And today, Jack Hitt is back with the Otis pamphlet,
在《独立宣言》甚至还在国父们的脑海中闪烁之前，就已经有了詹姆斯·奥蒂斯。你可以认为，这本小册子的故事就是美利坚合众国建国文件的故事。来自99%隐形节目与BBC工作室。这里是美国历史与100件物品。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天，杰克·希特带着奥蒂斯的小册子回来了，
America's forgotten Magna Carta and the life of the tragic hero who wrote it. The story of this pamphlet begins around 15 years before the Revolutionary War in 1761 in the tiny hamlet of Boston, Massachusetts. You know, at the time, Boston is this. tiny little port town, population 16,000. Wow. Yeah. So it's like a large university.
这本被美国遗忘的《大宪章》以及撰写它的悲剧英雄的一生。这本小册子的故事始于独立战争前大约15年的1761年，地点在马萨诸塞州波士顿的一个小村庄。你知道，当时的波士顿是一个小小的港口城市，人口1万6千人。哇。是的。所以它就像一所大型大学。
You all practically know everybody on campus, right? And certainly the people in power all knew each other. The city is so small you could walk from one side of it to the other in under an hour. During which time you might hear boats from Boston Harbor creaking and knocking into the docks, you might encounter pigs loose in the street. And if you weren't like in a church, you were probably in a tavern. And just remember, you know, we're talking about a time when no one is thinking of rebellion, no one's thinking of independence.
你们几乎认识校园里的每个人，对吧？当然，当权者也都互相认识。这座城市太小了，你可以在一个小时内从它的一端走到另一端。在此期间，你可能会听到波士顿港的船只发出吱吱嘎嘎的声响并撞击码头，你可能会遇到在街上游荡的猪。如果你不在教堂里，你可能就在酒馆里。请记住，你知道的，我们谈论的是一个没有人想到叛乱、没有人想到独立的时代。
These are British citizens in Boston at 1761, a full 15 years before the Declaration of Independence. And at the time, you know, they're mostly merchants trying to make a living and make something of their new life in America. But the living the merchants were making wasn't. always strictly legal. There's a good bit of smuggling, and everybody kind of knows it, you know. And a lot of it was about getting cheap French molasses out of the Caribbean and into the rum kegs. One of the big trades in the New England colonies was making rum, but the cheapest molasses was from the French Caribbean. So to get around heavy tariffs, merchants smuggled it in, and London was tired of it.
这些人在1761年的波士顿都是英国公民，比《独立宣言》早了整整15年。当时，你知道的，他们大多是商贩，试图在美洲维持生计并开创他们的新生活。但商人们维持生计的方式并不总是完全合法的。这里有相当多的走私，每个人心里其实都清楚，你知道的。其中很大一部分是从加勒比海获取廉价的法国糖蜜，然后塞进朗姆酒桶里。新英格兰殖民地的主要贸易之一就是酿造朗姆酒，但最便宜的糖蜜来自法属加勒比地区。为了绕过沉重的关税，商人们将其走私进来，而伦敦已经对此厌烦了。
They wanted those tax dollars, or I suppose those tax shillings. And so to catch these smugglers, London has issued these new kinds of search warrants called Rits of Assistance, and they're blanket warrants. I mean, you don't need any evidence. You can come aboard a ship day or night. You can go into a house or a warehouse anytime during the day with the barest of suspicions. And the reason they're called Rits of Assistance is the other aspect of them is that any agent who holds this piece of paper can kind of dragoon anyone into a...
他们想要那些税款，或者我猜是那些税令。因此为了抓捕这些走私者，伦敦发布了一种新型的搜查令，叫做“协助令”（Writs of Assistance），它们是全面搜查令。我的意思是，你不需要任何证据。你可以在白天或晚上的任何时候登船。你可以在白天根据最微弱的怀疑进入任何房屋或仓库。它们之所以被称为“协助令”，另一个方面在于，任何持有这张纸的特工都可以强征任何人来……
accompanying them on one of these searches. That's the assistance part. You command it. I mean, if they stop you, if one of these customs agents stops you and says, you have to help me, you have to help them. And so you have this like little mob practically coming into people's places and searching and looking for smuggled goods and everything. And the kicker was that the customs agents also had a financial incentive. They got a cut of whatever they found. So you've got agents prowling around town more and more like thugs and everyone is scared and on edge. And ostensibly the owner or the holder of this writ of assistance is an agent of the British government in some way? Oh yeah. These writs are executed, you know, by authority from London by the court in Massachusetts. Got it. So you really have
陪同他们进行这些搜查。这就是“协助”的部分。你必须服从。我的意思是，如果他们拦住你，如果这些海关特工拦住你并说，你必须帮我，你就得帮他们。所以你会看到几乎有一小群暴民进入人们的地方进行搜查，寻找走私货物等等。最糟糕的是，海关特工还有经济奖励。他们可以从查获的物品中分一杯羹。所以你会看到特工们像地痞流氓一样在镇上四处游荡，每个人都感到害怕和紧张。表面上，这些协助令的所有者或持有者在某种程度上是英国政府的特工吗？哦，是的。这些搜查令是由伦敦授权，通过马萨诸塞州的法院执行的。明白了。所以你真的有
this sort of like wonderful tempest in a teapot where you have, you know, the authorities are angry because duties are definitely being avoided. Taxes are not being collected. Money is not going into the king's coffers. So you have that. And then you have the merchants, and they're also furious about the abuse of these blanket warrants. So, you know, everybody's, like, ready for a courtroom battle.
这样一种奇妙的“茶杯里的风暴”，一方面，当局很生气，因为关税显然在被逃避。税款没有收上来。资金没有进入国王的金库。所以你有这个情况。然后你有了商人们，他们也对这些全面搜查令的滥用感到愤怒。所以，你知道的，每个人都准备好迎接一场法庭斗争。
And so the merchants bring a lawsuit and charge that, you know, these writs of assistance are illegal. Okay. Okay. So now it's February 1761. We're in the town hall. That's now called the old state house in Boston. And there were five British judges sitting in wigs and red robes at the front.
于是商人们提起诉讼，指控这些协助令是非法的。好的。好的。现在是1761年2月。我们在市政厅，现在被称为波士顿的老议会大厦。当时有五名英国法官戴着假发穿着红袍坐在前排。
And so you can imagine the public is permitted to come. And so the place is packed. First, the British government's lawyer gets up and makes the expected case in favor of the Ritz. Parliament authorized these search warrants and Parliament's word is law. Standard defense of the Ritz. Then it's the merchant's turn to try to convince the judges that the Ritz are illegal, and the first lawyer for the merchants gets up. A guy with a fabulous Dickensia name Oxenbridge Thatcher.
你可以想象，公众是被允许进入的。所以现场挤满了人。首先，英国政府的律师起身，为协助令做出了预期的辩护。议会授权了这些搜查令，议会的话就是法律。这是对搜查令的标准辩护。接下来轮到商人们试图说服法官搜查令是非法的，商人们的第一位律师站了起来。一个有着一个极具狄更斯风格名字的人——奥克森布里奇·萨彻（Oxenbridge Thatcher）。
Oxenbridge makes an equally predictable case on the opposite side. And he makes this very tidy argument about the Ritz, you know, citing precedent and so on. Oxenbridge sits down. So far, the packed audience doesn't seem moved. But the merchants have a second lawyer. Two, a hot-shot, hot-headed man who just joined their team. And this is James Otis. Now, I just got to try to describe James Otis to you.
奥克森布里奇在对立面上做出了同样意料之中的辩护。他围绕搜查令做出了非常干净利落的论证，你知道的，引用了判例等等。奥克森布里奇坐下了。到目前为止，满屋子的观众似乎并没有被触动。但商人们还有第二位律师。两个，一个刚刚加入他们团队的、雷厉风行、脾气暴躁的人。这就是詹姆斯·奥蒂斯。现在，我得试着向你们描述一下詹姆斯·奥蒂斯。
And he was sort of known as a really hot-shot kind of badass lawyer. He defended pirates in Nova Scotia. There was some young guys that went rioting on Guy Fawkes Day. He took their case, you know. And his friends had a nickname for him. He was called Furio. Oh, wow. You have to earn that one.
他有点像个雷厉风行的硬汉律师。他在新斯科舍省为海盗辩护。有些年轻人曾在盖伊·福克斯日闹事，他接了他们的案子。他的朋友们给他起了一个绰号。他被称为“福里奥”（Furio）。哦，哇。你得凭实力赢得这个外号。
And just to complicate things for Furio a little more, he had a personal history with the Chief Justice, a man named Thomas Hutchinson. Who at the time had just been appointed by the governor and the man he had passed over for this job, that the governor had passed over and given to Hutchinson was James Otis' father. Oh, let's see, yeah. So it's no secret. These two don't like each other. But they also fundamentally disagree. Otis quit his job to take this case. Until days before the trial, he was working for the government side, meaning he should have been arguing in favor of the Ritz.
为了给福里奥的生活再添点乱，他跟首席大法官托马斯·哈钦森（Thomas Hutchinson）有过节。此人当时刚刚被总督任命，而总督跳过并把这个职位给哈钦森的另一个人，正是詹姆斯·奥蒂斯的父亲。哦，明白了，是的。所以这已经不是秘密了。这两个人互相看不顺眼。但他们在根本上也存在分歧。奥蒂斯辞掉了工作来接这个案子。直到审判前几天，他还在为政府一方工作，这意味着他本该为搜查令辩护。
But he quit the job and dramatically offered to represent the merchants for free. Wow. Now, you can say, you know, he did this for principal, or he did this because he still steamed about his old man. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Whatever. It's pretty exciting stuff. So Otis takes to the floor, and he speaks for five hours.
但他辞去了工作，并戏剧性地提出免费为商人辩护。哇。现在，你可以说，他这么做是为了原则，或者他这么做是因为他还在为他老爹的事生气。管他呢。这真是太刺激了。于是奥蒂斯走上法庭，讲了五个小时。
Now, let me just say something about five hours. I think people forget that way before television and radio, before telegraph, before even magazines, oratory was a whole other kind of, you know, public entertainment, really. I always love to remind people that, you know, we law the Stephen Douglas' Abraham Lincoln debates. There were seven Lincoln Douglas debates, each were three hours long. but people had all the time in the world, and this was great. So when I say he carried on for five hours, I mean, that was just like, this is a good show. That's what that means. Totally. They're binge in a Netflix show.
现在，让我对这五个小时说点什么。我认为人们忘记了，早在电视和无线电、电报甚至杂志出现之前，演讲完全是另一种形式的、真正的公众娱乐。我总是喜欢提醒人们，你知道的，我们赞美斯蒂芬·道格拉斯与亚伯拉罕·林肯的辩论。林肯和道格拉斯有过七场辩论，每场长达三个小时。但人们有的是时间，而且这很棒。所以当我说他滔滔不绝地讲了五个小时，我的意思是，这就像是一场精彩的演出。这就是那个意思。完全正确。他们就像在疯狂刷Netflix的剧集。
Right. This is Sopranos, season one. And you're just hitting next episode, next episode. Exactly. And we know that he's Piroe, right? He's a thunderous kind of fellow. So, you know, he warns the audience. He says, I'm going to make this rather dangerous argument and even suggests one that may end up destroying me.
没错。这就是《黑道家族》第一季。然后你一直在点下一集，下一集。完全正确。我们知道他是福里奥，对吧？他是个雷霆万钧的人。所以，你知道的，他警告观众。他说，我要做一个相当危险的论证，甚至暗示这个论证可能最终会毁了我。
And as we know them, these are the words he said right at the beginning. beginning of his talk. He says, let the consequences be what they will. I am determined to proceed. The only principles of public conduct that are worthy of a gentleman or a man are to sacrifice his state, ease, health and applause, and even life itself to the sacred call of his country. Otis is preparing his audience. Whatever he's about to say about these writs of assistance, these search warrants, might be so crazy that it could threaten everything. And in fact, you know, he comes right in and lands it. He says, this writ, he says, appears to me the worst instrument of arbitrary power, the most destructive of English liberty, and the fundamental principles of law that ever was found in an English law book.
正如我们所知，这是他在演讲一开始就说的话。他说：让后果随它去吧。我决心继续前进。一个绅士或男子汉值得拥有的唯一公共行为准则，就是为了祖国的神圣召唤而牺牲他的财产、安逸、健康和掌声，甚至是生命本身。奥蒂斯在为他的观众做心理建设。无论他接下来要对这些协助令、这些搜查令说些什么，都可能是如此疯狂，以至于会威胁到一切。事实上，你知道的，他开门见山地抛出了观点。他说，在我看来，这个搜查令是专制权力中最糟糕的工具，是对英国自由和法律基本原则最具毁灭性的破坏，是英国法律书籍中从未出现过的。
Swinging. What he's saying is that it's inherently wrong for thugs to break into your home without due process. He says, now one of the most essential branches. of English liberty is the freedom of one's house. And then he brings out this sort of cherished old metaphor. He says, a man's house is his castle. And whilst he is quiet, he is as well guarded as a prince in his castle. This writ, if it should be declared legal, would totally annihilate this privilege.
重拳出击。他的意思是，暴徒在没有正当程序的情况下闯入你的家，这是天理难容的。他说，现在，英国自由最本质的分支之一就是住宅的自由。然后他搬出了这个珍爱已久的古老隐喻。他说，人的家就是他的城堡。当他在家安静时，他就和城堡里的王子一样受到保护。这个搜查令，如果被宣布为合法，将彻底消灭这一特权。
And then he goes right there. He says, no acts of parliament can establish such a rich. writ, no matter how Parliament might ward this writ, it would be void. Well, gulp. What is so radical about this is the fact that he's questioning the very validity of parliament, that there might be some laws that are deeper, more fundamental than the laws of parliament. Because what he's basically saying here is that the king's law doesn't stand up against natural law. That's right. He's saying Parliament's law. So understand at this time, you know, no one has really brought into an American courtroom this idea of natural rights, these notions that
然后他直接指出。他说，任何议会法案都不能确立这样的搜查令，无论议会如何措辞这个搜查令，它都是无效的。好吧，倒吸一口凉气。这之所以如此激进，是因为他在性质上质疑了议会的合法性，即可能存在某些比议会法律更深层、更基本的法律。因为他在这里基本上是在说，国王的法律无法与自然法对抗。没错。他说的是议会的法律。所以请理解，在那个时候，你知道的，没有人真正将这种自然权利的思想、这些甚至还没有被写下来的概念带入美国的法庭中，
haven't even been written down yet. These five appointed judges, they totally believe that parliament was supreme. No exceptions. So remember, in the previous century, you know, a king had lost his head and another his throne in this like centuries-long struggle that culminated in this idea that the law of parliament is supreme. And that's the word they always used. The law of parliament is Supreme. So here he is saying like this right to privacy and these British rights in general predate Parliament or any government. It's certainly older than any of Parliament's mealy laws. And so how is this panel of judges who represent Parliament's mealy laws? How are they reacting to this? Well, the judges must have been floored. But you know, the merchants in the room,
这五位被任命的法官，他们坚信议会是至高无上的。没有任何例外。所以请记住，在上个世纪，你知道的，一个国王失去了脑袋，另一个失去了王位，在这场历时数个世纪的斗争中，最终确立了“议会法律至高无上”的思想。这就是他们经常使用的词。议会的法律是至高无上的。所以在这里，他说这种隐私权和这些英国人的权利一般都先于议会或任何政府。它肯定比议会任何软弱的法律都要古老。那么，代表着议会软弱法律的这个法官小组，他们对此作何反应？嗯，法官们一定被震惊了。但是你知道，屋子里的商人们，
they were moved. They thought, hey, you know, we would just try. to wiggle out of some smuggling fees, but now we're practically the knights of the roundtable in the court of King Arthur. The truth is, we don't know exactly what James Otis said in that room. There isn't a transcript of his speech. There was no minutes taker for the court. In fact, we only have one set of notes from it. There was really only one young guy who frantically scribbled down everything that he could get down on paper before it was all over. 25-year-old, freshly minted lawyer. John Adams. Wow.
他们被触动了。他们想，嘿，你知道的，我们本来只是想在一些走私税上打个擦边球，但现在我们简直成了亚瑟王宫廷里的圆桌骑士。事实是，我们并不知道詹姆斯·奥蒂斯在那间屋子里具体说了什么。没有他演讲的文字记录。法庭没有记录员。事实上，我们只有一套当时的记录。真的只有一个年轻人拼命地把他在结束前能抓到的所有东西都涂鸦在纸上。25岁，刚出道的年轻律师。约翰·亚当斯。哇。
Yes. In the room. That John Adams. For people who don't know. I mean, I don't know. That John Adams, founding father, second president, and kind of the scholar of the group. You know what I mean? He's not only the scholar and the intellectual, but, you know, Adams, he kept his diaries.
是的。在房间里。那个约翰·亚当斯。对于不了解的人来说。我的意思是，我也不太清楚。那个约翰·亚当斯，国父，第二任总统，算是那一群人里的学者。你知道我的意思吗？他不仅是学者和知识分子，而且，你知道的，亚当斯保留了写日记的习惯。
He's kind of the minutes taker of the entire revolution. I mean, we have his commentary on just about everything. And in fact, here, he famously, right. a little later, Otis was a flame of fire. Every man of an immense crowded audience appeared to me to go away as I did, ready to take arms against writs of assistance. To be clear, Adams isn't a merchant.
他可以说是整个革命的会议记录员。我的意思是，关于几乎所有事情，我们都能找到他的评论。事实上，在这里，他后来有一段著名的言论。稍后，奥蒂斯就像是一团火焰。在场的拥挤人群中，每个人给我的感觉都跟我一样，随时准备拿起武器反抗搜查令。需要说明的是，亚当斯并不是个商人。
He has no money at stake here. He's just a young lawyer who is swept up in the brilliance and prescience of James Otis before him. Later, he swoons a little bit and he says, and this is this very famous line about this little moment, then and there the child independence was born. Even the chief judge Hutchinson would later marvel at the magnitude of this moment. Later, Hutchinson writes his own little memoir and remembers that, you know, basically all the
他在这里没有经济利益。他只是一个年轻的律师，被他面前詹姆斯·奥蒂斯的才华和远见深深折服。后来，他有点激动地说，关于这个短暂的瞬间，有一句非常著名的话：正是在那个时候，独立的幼虫诞生了。甚至首席法官哈钦森后来也对这一时刻的重大意义惊叹不已。后来，哈钦森写了自己的小回忆录，回忆说，基本上所有
troubles in the colonies stem back to this time and remembers that Otis before this speech, Otis swore to him that he would, quote, set the province in flames. His five-hour oration may have radicalized the crowd. of merchants and onlookers, but it failed to win the case. He lost the case, but he kind of won in the battle of ideas, at least in the crowd. Absolutely. And won in terms of his reputation. Otis becomes a politician. He's elected to the Massachusetts House. And meanwhile, over the next few years, he's taking this electrifying speech and refining his ideas,
殖民地的麻烦都可以追溯到这个时候，并回忆起奥蒂斯在发表这篇演讲之前，曾向他发誓说，他要“让这个省份陷入烈火之中”。他那长达五个小时的演说可能让在场的商人和平民变得激进起来，但它并没有赢得这场官司。他输了官司，但在思想的较量中他赢了，至少在群众当中是这样的。绝对是的。而且在名誉上也赢了。奥蒂斯成了一名政治家。他当选为马萨诸塞州议员。与此同时，在接下来的几年里，他一直在将这篇振奋人心的演讲进行打磨和提炼他的思想，
turning the argument into something he'll write down on paper in one of the most popular forms of political commentary of the day. the pamphlet. You know, this is three years after the speech when this pamphlet comes out. So he's taken this idea of like these natural rights, these British liberties, these inherent rights that predate government, and he's kind of pulling it all together. And in 1764, he publishes a little pamphlet with a big title, The Rights of the British Colonies, asserted and proved. Otis writes this pamphlet, and it does kind of go viral. In America, it goes through like three editions. It's published in London, so they're discussing it in Parliament. Wow.
把这个论点写成纸面文字，成为了当时最受欢迎的政治评论形式之一：小册子。你知道的，这本小册子是在演讲三年后问世的。所以他吸收了自然权利、英国自由、政府出现之前就固有的权利这些概念，并把它们融会贯通。1764年，他出版了一本标题很大但篇幅很小的小册子，叫做《阐明并证明英国殖民地的权利》。奥蒂斯写了这本小册子，它确实有点像病毒一样传开了。在美洲，它印了大约三个版本。它也在伦敦出版，所以议会在讨论它。哇。
So, yeah, this is a serious piece of paper, right? And it made all the more serious by some of the crazy ideas that are being thrown out from this pamphlet. He says, and I think he believes in his heart that he's trying to describe British government. He's describing what he thinks once existed in England, but in fact he's kind of outlining what America is about to become. Otis goes much further in this pamphlet than he went in his courtroom speech. And he starts to outline a version of a country that was so foreign at the time it would put his life in jeopardy. Which is strange, because to us today, these crazy ideas sound so familiar. They're almost boring.
所以，是的，这是一份意义重大的文件，对吧？由于这本小册子里抛出了一些疯狂的想法，它显得更加意义重大。他说，而且我相信他发自内心地认为他是在描述英国政府。他描述的是他认为以前在英国存在的东西，但实际上他是在勾勒美洲即将成为的模样。奥蒂斯在这本小册子里比他在法庭上的演讲走得更远。他开始勾勒一个当时极其陌生的国家版本，这甚至会让他的生命处于危险之中。这很奇怪，因为对今天的我们来说，这些疯狂的想法听起来太熟悉了。它们几乎让人觉得无聊。
For example, in the pamphlet, he lays out a structure for government. Instead of the supremacy of parliament, he describes three branches working in tandem. And he even uses the phrase checks and balances to describe how they work harmoniously. But of course, understand me. Parliament does not see it that way. He also takes issue with how the colonists are taxed, even though they don't have a vote in elections. He says, the very act of taxing exercised over those who are not represented appears to me depriving them of one of their most essential rights as free men. You know, this idea is what sort of boils down to the bumper sticker.
例如，他在小册子中规划了一个政府结构。他没有强调议会至上，而是描述了三个协同工作的部门。他甚至用了“制衡”这个词来描述它们是如何和谐运作的。但是当然，请理解我。议会可不这么看。他对殖民者在没有选举投票权的情况下如何被征税也提出了异议。他说：“对那些没有代表权的人行使征税这一行为，在我看来，是剥夺了他们作为自由人最基本的权利之一。”你知道，这个想法后来浓缩成了一句标语。
Taxation without representation is tyranny. Right? One of the central sort of mottos of the revolution. That's in this pamphlet. And he evokes this idea in this dramatic moment that our rights aren't given to us by government, but by God. He says, Parliament cannot make two and two five. And he says, you know, the only person that can make natural law. like two and two is four, is God.
无代表不纳税，就是暴政。对吧？革命的核心座右铭之一。这就在这本小册子里。他在一个戏剧性的时刻唤起了这样一个想法：我们的权利不是政府赋予的，而是上帝赋予的。他说，议会不能把二加二变成五。他说，你知道，只有能制定自然法则的人——比如二加二等于四——才是上帝。
Yeah. You know, and every founding person would kind of take this idea and make it their own. You know, Adams later talks about rights granted by our maker. And of course, Jefferson famously says, you know, inalienable rights endowed by our creator. But he's also imagining a version of America that is far more of a utopia than most of the founding fathers would conceive of. And he has this one passage. Check this out. He says at one point, the colonists are. by the law of nature freeborn, as indeed all men are, white or black. Whoa. Yeah, James Otis,
是的。你知道，每一位国父都会采纳这个想法并使其成为自己的东西。你知道，亚当斯后来谈到了造物主赋予的权利。当然，杰斐逊也有一句名言，你知道的，那就是造物主赋予的不可剥夺的权利。但他也想象着一个比大多数国父所能想象的更具乌托邦色彩的美洲版本。他有一段这样的文字。你看这个。他在某个地方说，殖民者根据自然法生而自由，正如所有人一样，无论白人还是黑人。哇。是的，詹姆斯·奥蒂斯，
in this pamphlet goes there, because this is the absolute logic of all of these ideas. Absolutely, absolutely. And he says, slavery threatens to reduce Europe and America to the ignorance and barbarity of the dark ages. Wow. I love that he sees it all. Right. It's all there. and he just carries it forward because he's hot-headed, you know, he's furio. Yeah. He's going to take his argument to the end. Otis wasn't trying to start a revolution with this pamphlet.
在这本小册子里触及了这一点，因为这就是所有这些想法的绝对逻辑。完全正确，完全正确。他说，奴役威胁着要把欧洲和美洲带回黑暗时代的无知和野蛮中。哇。我喜欢他看清了一切。对吧。全都在这里了，他只是把它推向前进，因为他是个急脾气，你知道的，他很狂热。是的。他要把他的论点进行到底。奥蒂斯写这本小册子并不是为了挑起革命。
Remember, it's lovingly, awkwardly called the rights of British colonies asserted and proved. He wants to reform Britain, not start a new country. But the logic he sets out, it's like a grenade. Once he asserted that natural law supersedes parliamentary law, that there are rights so fundamental that no government can take them away, the tab had been pulled
记住，它那充满爱意又略显尴尬的名字叫《阐明并证明英国殖民地的权利》。他想改革英国，而不是建立一个新的国家。但他提出的逻辑就像一颗手榴弹。一旦他断言自然法高于议会法，即存在如此基础的权利，以至于任何政府都无法将其剥夺，拉环就已经被拉开了
and the grenade thrown. So once Otis's pamphlet is published, what happened? Like, how is Oda's being perceived? Well, you know, at first, of course, Otis is this great hero, and this is a very powerful and strong pamphlet, and here in the States,
手榴弹也被扔了出去。所以，一旦奥蒂斯的小册子出版，发生了什么？人们是如何看待奥蒂斯的？嗯，你知道，起初，奥蒂斯当然是个伟大的英雄，这是一本非常有力且强硬的小册子，在这里，在美国本土，
they think it's all great. Now, it does get published in London. And, you know, like I said, this argument that Parliament is not supreme. It's just, you know, that is not going to sit. I did find this, the eminent jurist of the day was a man named Lord Mansfield, and he did offer this opinion, quote, it is said the man is mad. The book is full of wildness. Meanwhile, in the colonies, counter pamphlets are written, customs officers start bad-mouthing him, so Otis responds.
他们觉得一切都很好。现在，它确实在伦敦出版了。而且，就像我说的，这个关于议会并非至高无上的论点。这只是，你知道的，这是行不通的。我确实发现了这一点，当时杰出的法学家是一位名叫曼斯菲尔德勋爵的人，他确实给出了这样的意见，引述如下：“据说此人疯了。这本书充满了狂野。”与此同时，在殖民地，反对的小册子被写了出来，海关官员开始说他的坏话，于是奥蒂斯做出了回应。
In follow-up pamphlets, hot takes flying back and forth. And the consequences are becoming more and more dramatic. People are asking some hard questions. Like, what do you mean parliament is? Supreme. Isn't that treason to say that? Don't you get hung for that? You know, these are the questions that are floating around. Yeah. And so how does Otis take that? Increasingly, in these newspaper articles that he writes or in these other pamphlets that are sort of the follow-ups, he starts backtracking. He doesn't want people to think that he's not a good Brit, that he's not a loyal British citizen swearing allegiance to the king and recognizing the supremacy of parliament. He is, after all, a politician in Massachusetts.
在后续的小册子中，激烈的观点来回飞溅。后果也变得越来越戏剧化。人们开始提出一些尖锐的问题。比如，你说的议会至上是什么意思？这么说难道不是叛国吗？你会不会因此而被绞死？你知道，这些都是在四处飘荡的问题。是的。那么奥蒂斯对此作何反应？渐渐地，在他写的这些报纸文章中，或者在他作为后续推出的其他小册子中，他开始打退堂鼓。他不想让人们认为他不是一个好英国人，认为他不是一个效忠国王并承认议会至上的忠实英国公民。毕竟，他是马萨诸塞州的一名政治家。
a British politician. He writes in one of his subsequent pamphlets, things like, of course, Parliament is the supreme sovereign power. And then he says, you know, Parliament, quote, remains the Supreme judge from whose final determination there is no appeal. Wow. So you're like, oh, wait, what, what happened, Otis? Yeah. What happened? James, what's going on? And you get a sense that Otis might be just even a little bit afraid. Yeah. Yeah. They're talking about treason. Right. The last one is kind of hard to read, because it's so full of this kind of language. Check this out. If there's anything offensive, he's referring to his previous pamphlets.
一个英国政治家。他在他随后的一本小册子里写下了这样的话：当然，议会是至高无上的权力。然后他说，你知道，议会“依然是最高法官，其最终裁决无可上诉。”哇。所以你会觉得，哦，等等，什么，怎么了，奥蒂斯？是的。怎么了？詹姆斯，到底怎么回事？你会有一种感觉，奥蒂斯可能甚至有点害怕了。是的。是的。他们在谈论叛国罪。对吧。最后一句有点难读，因为它充满了这种语言。看看这个。如果其中有什么冒犯之处，他指的是他以前的小册子。
He says, if there is anything offensive in either, I am heartily sorry. And then he refers to himself in the third person and says that the author of these previous pamphlets has given me authority in his name, humbly to ask pardon, for the least iota that may have displeased his superiors. superiors. Wow. And yeah. What do you, what do you make of this? What is your read on him backtracking? Well, I mean, I think he was afraid. You know, the pushback was fervent. John Adams, once again, always with his diaries and notes, always observing the scene, writes that Otis was called a reprobate, an apostate and a traitor in every street in Boston, the indignation of all his political friends, against him was universal. So now, Otis is a pariah, the town goat.
他说：“如果其中有任何冒犯之处，我深表歉意。”然后他用第三人称指代自己，并说这些先前小册子的作者已经授权他以他的名义，谦卑地为可能已经惹恼他的上级的哪怕最微小的细节请求宽恕。上级。哇。还有。你觉得，你对这件事怎么看？你对他的退缩有什么看法？嗯，我的意思是，我觉得他是害怕了。你知道，反弹非常强烈。约翰·亚当斯再次带着他的日记和笔记，一直在观察现场，他写道，奥蒂斯在波士顿的每一条街道上都被称为叛徒、背叛者和卖国贼，他所有政治朋友对他的愤怒都是普遍的。所以现在，奥蒂斯成了一个被遗弃的人，成了全镇的替罪羊。
Yeah. You can see why he would begin to acquiesce, why he would begin to capitulate. You know, we, we lament him backtracking here. But there's nothing to stop what he's already started in a way. Right, right. And, you know, I think, you know, Otis, in that pamphlet, he floats so many radical ideas. I mean, when he goes off about racial equality, he's speaking to an audience that almost 100% can't hear anything he's saying. Right?
是的。你可以理解他为什么会开始默许，为什么会开始屈服。你知道，我们在这里为他的退缩感到惋惜。但在某种程度上，已经没有什么能阻止他已经开始的事情了。对吧，对吧。而且，你知道，我认为，奥蒂斯在那本小册子中提出了如此多的激进观点。我的意思是，当他大谈特谈种族平等时，他面对的观众几乎百分之百都听不懂他在说什么。对吧？
He is. He is in a world of his own making. He's in an America that wouldn't exist for, well, doesn't exist yet. Yeah. But certainly, he sees it. Right. And I think all of his boldness in the pamphlet, once it hits the, you know, the buzzsaw of all this criticism, Talk of treason, you know, even the gallows, you know, makes him realize, well, man, maybe, maybe I did go a little too far.
他是。他生活在自己创造的世界里。他身处一个——嗯，现在还不存在的美洲。是的。但毫无疑问，他看到了。对吧。我想他在小册子里表现出的所有勇敢，一旦撞上所有这些批评的电锯，
But he does back up. He does retreat. And it's kind of horrible to read. This is where things start to get Shakespearean. Otis knows he's not going to win the fight against parliament. So he starts backing off his revolutionary rhetoric. But he's still mad. He's still Furio, after all.
谈论叛国罪，你知道的，甚至是绞刑架，你知道的，让他意识到，好吧，伙计，也许，也许我真的有点太过火了。
So he starts fighting any fight that he might. be able to win. He starts publicly feuding in the papers with some of the customs agents who disagree with him. They're always fighting each other in the papers. In one article, he calls them, quote, superlative blockheads. So one day, Otis learns that one of these superlative blockheads, a customs agent named John Robinson, is coming to Boston. And Otis takes to the newspaper to speak again about the natural rights of man. And the Boston Gazette, he writes this line. I have a natural right if I can get no other satisfaction than to break his head. Now we're parodying himself.
但他确实退缩了。他确实撤退了。读起来感觉有点糟糕。事情就是从这里开始变得有点像莎士比亚悲剧的。奥蒂斯知道他打不赢反对议会的斗争。所以他开始收回他的革命言论。但他还是很生气。毕竟，他仍然是个狂热分子。
Parody or not, Otis tries to make good on his threat. Otis prowls the bars one night looking for Robinson and finds him, and he challenges him to a duel. Then and there, and Robinson just grabs Otis by the nose and drags him around. Now, they both have walking sticks. So they just start beating the crap out of each other. But Robinson gets the upper hand and seriously bashes Otis's skull in with his stick. He is seriously injured.
所以他开始寻找任何他可能赢得的战斗。他在报纸上公开与一些不同意他的海关官员争吵。他们总是在报纸上互相攻击。在一篇文章中，他称他们为“最高级的笨蛋”。所以有一天，奥蒂斯得知这些最高级的笨蛋之一、一个名叫约翰·罗宾逊的海关官员要来波士顿。奥蒂斯再次登上报纸，谈论人的自然权利。他在《波士顿公报》上写下了这样一句话：如果我找不到别的发泄方式，我有一种天然的权利去打破他的脑袋。现在他在自嘲。
Brain injury. A few months afterwards, Adams visits him and sees the healed gash and has always in his diary. You could lay a finger in it. Oh, wow. Yeah, so it's bad. And then it just gets worse. The injury proves to be devastating. Otis starts falling apart right there in front of all the townspeople of Boston.
无论是自嘲还是别的什么，奥蒂斯试图兑现他的威胁。一天晚上，奥蒂斯在酒吧里四处寻找罗宾逊，终于找到了他，并向他发起了决斗挑战。就在当场，罗宾逊一把抓住奥蒂斯的鼻子，把他拖来拖去。现在，他们俩都拿着手杖。所以他们开始狠狠地殴打对方。但罗宾逊占了上风，用手杖狠狠地砸破了奥蒂斯的头骨。他受了重伤。
Remember, this is like a college campus, and the hot-shot hot-head lawyer who took on the government with all the bravado in the world is now being described as a, quote, miserable vagabond, rolling in the streets and gutters, a drunkard, a madman, shooting guns out of his windows. And then he does something poetically tragic. One night he is in a rage
脑部受伤。几个月后，亚当斯去探望他，看到了那道已经愈合的伤口，并且一如既往地写在了日记里。你可以在上面放进一根手指。哦，哇。是的，所以情况很糟糕。然后事情变得更糟了。事实证明，这次受伤是毁灭性的。奥蒂斯就在波士顿全体镇民的面前开始崩溃了。
and one of the merchants in town writes in his diary, Mr. Otis got into a mad freak tonight and broke a great many windows in the townhouse. And remember, that's where he made his speech. And he goes there one night and smashes out all the windows.
记住，这就像一个大学校园，那个曾经以世上所有的虚张声势与政府对抗的高傲而急躁的律师，现在被描述为一个“悲惨的流浪者，在街道和水沟里打滚，一个酒鬼，一个疯子，从窗户里开枪”。然后他做了一件富有诗意的悲剧性事情。一天晚上，他处于狂怒之中，
Oh, where he made his first fiery speech. Right. He just goes there. at night and just spashed out the windows. Just throws, yeah, rocks through all the windows. Oh, my God. Yeah. Yeah.
镇上的一个商人在日记里写道，奥蒂斯先生今晚发疯了，砸碎了市政厅里的很多窗户。记住，那就是他发表演讲的地方。他有一天晚上去那里，砸碎了所有的窗户。
So, but then in 1771, he's declared lunatic. L-U-N-A-T-I-C-K. Yeah, yeah. The pre-Webster spotlight line of lunatic. That's right. Which is some sort of like category of mental state, you know, at the time. Otis leaves Boston, leaves politics and law and all the arguments about parliament and the superlative blockheads, and he retires to a,
哦，他发表第一次慷慨激昂演讲的地方。对吧。他只是在夜里去那里，砸碎了窗户。只是把石头扔进所有的窗户里。哦，天哪。是的。是的。
farm to convales and stops writing pamphlets and newspaper articles, stops outlining a version of a country only he can see. But pretty soon, others start to see it too. Samuel Adams spreads Otis's argument, now filed into the sharpest slogan of the age, no taxation without representation. In 1768, John Hancock's ship, the Liberty, gets seized while smuggling Madeira wine. Hancock comes out the other side, a revolutionary, throwing in with the Sons of Liberty putting his fortune behind the cause. Some of them turn fast like that. Others, like Jefferson and Washington, come to it slowly, talking themselves into treason one year at a time. But here's the thing. They came to it together. They had committees and taverns and each other. When Hancock needed a lawyer to defend him,
所以，但是在1771年，他被宣布为疯子。L-U-N-A-T-I-C-K。是的，是的。韦伯斯特词典出版前对疯子的拼写。没错。这在当时某种程度上是一种精神状态的分类，你知道的。奥蒂斯离开波士顿，离开政治和法律，以及所有关于议会和最高级笨蛋的争论，他退隐到一个
his friend John Adams took the case. And won. It was a whole crowd of men radicalizing in same direction at once, but not Otis. So the whole war happens. He is, you know, taking arrest at the farm as to not aggravate his lunacy. And then we win. Right. Yorktown, the British surrender. And it's 1783.
农场去疗养，不再写小册子和报纸文章，不再勾勒一个只有他自己才能看到的国家版本。但很快，其他人也开始看到了。塞缪尔·亚当斯传播了奥蒂斯的论点，现在这个论点被提炼成那个时代最尖锐的口号：无代表不纳税。1768年，约翰·汉考克的船“自由号”在走私马德拉酒时被扣押。汉考克从另一端走了出来，成了一个革命者，加入了自由之子，将他的财富投入到这项事业中。他们中的一些人很快就转变了。另一些人，比如杰斐逊和华盛顿，则慢慢地转变，一年又一年地把自己说服得去叛国。但关键是。他们是一起走向这一步的。他们有委员会、小酒馆和彼此。当汉考克需要律师为他辩护时，
And we're about to, we're en route to signing the Treaty of Paris and become a country. So somewhere in that year, John Hancock decides to have a big party. You know, he is John Hancock. And he invites everybody. It's a big party. And somebody, I think it's Hancock, it comes up with the idea that, you know, we should invite James Otis. Because, you know, he was there at the beginning, right? Yeah, yeah.
他的朋友约翰·亚当斯接下了这个案子。并且赢了。这是一大群人同时向同一个方向激进化，但奥蒂斯除外。所以整个战争发生了。他，你知道的，在农场里休息，以免加重他的精神错乱。然后我们赢了。对吧。约克敦，英军投降了。那是1783年。
This is right at the time when people realize, you know, books are going to be written about them now. Statues are going to be carved. They won. We're starting a new country. And so they invite Otis out of respect, you know. And he comes. There's not much written about this party, but you can't imagine it. In the Hancock Manor, the finest home in all of Massachusetts Bay,
我们正准备，我们正在前往签署《巴黎条约》并成为一个国家的路上。所以在那个时候的某个时候，约翰·汉考克决定举办一场盛大的派对。你知道的，他可是约翰·汉考克。他邀请了所有人。这是一个盛大的派对。有人，我想是汉考克，想出了一个主意，你知道的，我们应该邀请詹姆斯·奥蒂斯。因为，你知道的，他在一开始就在那里，对吧？是的，是的。
they must have been drinking Madeira wine, John Hancock's famous smuggled good, or the rum punch that was the preferred drink of the revolutionary elite. And the toasts, there must have been toasts. A war had been fought and won. lives had been lost, and an unlikely colony had beaten the most powerful empire on earth. And all the while, James Otis is there. Old friends, familiar faces, celebrating the victory of a battle, he'd surrendered. He could probably imagine the statues and the plaques, the parades, and the holidays to come. What was this like for Otis? Most of what we know comes from what a nephew of his recorded.
他们当时一定在喝马德拉酒——约翰·汉考克的著名走私货，或者罗姆潘趣酒，这是革命精英们最爱喝的饮品。还有祝酒，当时一定有过祝酒。一场战争已经打过并赢得了胜利。生命已经消逝，一个原本不可能成事的殖民地战胜了地球上最强大的帝国。而詹姆斯·奥蒂斯自始至终都在那里。老朋友们，熟悉的面孔，正庆祝着一场他曾中途退出的战役的胜利。他大概能想象得出未来的雕像、牌匾、游行和节日。对奥蒂斯来说，这究竟是什么感觉？我们所知道的大多来自于他的一位侄子所记录的内容。
And so the nephew escorts him, not only out of the party, out of Boston, and back to the farm. And we just have this one sort of bleak note that, you know, immediately after this dinner, his nephew tells us he just kind of breaks down the way the nephew describes it is. There was a visible oscillation of his intellect. He was overwhelmed by the recollection of past days, impressed probably with grieve. greater force by the presence of Hancock and others of the convives and by the scene altogether. You know, it's hard to imagine what Otis was thinking when he was at that party. But, you know, very few of us ever get to see the road not taken. You know, we take our road.
于是侄子护送他离开派对，离开波士顿，回到了农场。我们只留下了一条凄凉的记录：你知道的，就在这次晚宴后不久，他的侄子告诉我们，他整个人崩溃了，侄子是这样描述的：他的智力出现了肉眼可见的摇摆。他被对过去日子的回忆压垮了，汉考克和其他欢宴者的出现以及整个场景，可能给他带来了更大强度的悲伤震撼。你知道的，很难想象奥蒂斯在那个派对上时心里在想什么。但是，你知道的，我们当中极少数人能有机会看到那条未曾选择的路。你知道的，我们走的是我们自己的路。
You know, the significance of the Frost poem, of course, is that we all take the roads we take and then we make up lies about how we made the right decision. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right. That's what that poem's actually about. Because most of us never get to see the other path. Yeah. But Otis did. He goes to that dinner and there it is. The other path.
你知道的，弗罗斯特那首诗的意义当然在于，我们都走了我们所选择的路，然后编造谎言说自己做了正确的决定。对，对，对。没错。那首诗实际上讲的就是这个。因为我们大多数人永远看不到另一条路。对。但奥蒂斯看到了。他去了那场晚宴，那条路就在那里。另一条路。
They're all sitting around him. I can't imagine just the gravity of that revelation. Certainly that alone would have made a man insane. He was alone when he was a revolution. and he was alone when he wasn't a revolutionary. He was a man always out of step. But it took him taking that first step. The revolution he missed required a singular voice
他们都坐在他周围。我简直无法想象那种启示的分量。仅此一点就足以让一个人发疯。当他是个革命者时他是孤独的；当他不再是革命者时，他依然是孤独的。他是一个总是与时代步伐不一致的人。但他迈出了那第一步。他所错过的这场革命需要一个独一无二的声音
to crack through the status quo and electrify the people who came after him. He's taken back to the country, back to the farm, and a few months later, it was just a lovely May, spring afternoon, a nice shower started. He steps out onto the porch of the Osborne farm in Andover, and a single bolt of lightning came out of the sky and killed him.
来打破现状，并电击那些在他之后到来的人。他被带回乡下，回到农场，几个月后，那只是一个可爱的五月春日下午，下起了一阵细雨。他走到安多弗奥斯本农场的门廊上，一道闪电从天而降，击中了并杀死了他。
What? Get out of here. Yeah. That's how he died. Oh, my God. It's like mythical. It's not even Shakespearean. It's like, it is like Greek and Roman and Shakespearean and biblical, biblical.
什么？开玩笑吧。对。他就是这样死的。噢，天哪。这简直太神话了。这甚至不是莎士比亚式的。这就像希腊神话、罗马神话、莎士比亚式以及圣经式的，圣经式的。
All in one. I think it's sort of fitting that he is taken out like a god. You know, I think that's the final, you know, sort of compliment for Otis. This is here, here's how you know, Zeus will take you down. Absolutely. What an amazing story, Jacket. This is so much fun. Thanks for letting us all know about the tragedy of James Otis.
全都有了。我觉得他像神一样被带走，倒也挺合适的。你知道，我认为这是对奥蒂斯的最后一种，怎么说呢，赞美。这就是——你看，宙斯就是这样把你带走的。绝对是这样。多棒的故事啊，杰克。太有趣了。谢谢你让我们了解詹姆斯·奥蒂斯的悲剧。
Really, something else. It's the glory in the tragedy. I mean, there's so many great things that come from Otis and just, God, wow, the price of that kind of enthusiasm, that kind of daring, and that kind of ambition. That's James Otis. Jack Hitt is an author and contributing editor of Harper's, The New York Times Magazine, and This American Life. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios.
真是别具一格。那是悲剧中的辉煌。我的意思是，奥蒂斯带来了那么多伟大的东西，天哪，这种热情、这种胆识、这种野心的代价，真是惊人。这就是詹姆斯·奥蒂斯。杰克·希特是《哈珀斯》杂志、《纽约时报杂志》和《This American Life》的作家兼特约编辑。《美国历史与100件物品》是 99% Invisible 和 BBC Studios 联合制作的节目。
It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. Our series producers are Priscilla Alabi, Brenna Dahldorf, Ellie Lightfoot. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family,
本节目由我罗曼·马尔斯主持和策划。我们的系列制作人是普里西拉·阿拉比、布伦娜·达尔多夫、艾丽·莱特富特。我们的副制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，查理·布兰登·金混音。事实核查由艾米·布雷肯完成。我们的主题曲由 Swan Real 创作。来自 99% Invisible，我们的执行制作人是凯茜·2。来自 BBC Studios，我们的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特。封面艺术由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。99% Invisible 是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，
headquartered in Beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心上城。BBC Studios 总部位于美丽的伦敦西部白城。如果你想与我们取得联系或有物品让我们考虑，请发电子邮件至 100Objects@99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。